it is andrew heaney on the mound for the
halos this afternoon coming off the
start on tuesday at yankee stadium in
which he lasted only three innings four
and six on the year as andrew makes
career start number 99 in his angels
career today he chases it misses that
fastball struck him out and the inning
is over david fletcher coming off a
perfect four for four night yesterday
and again trying to pick up a 20-game
hitting streak this afternoon that might
just do it
vintage fletch
a doink into left center field steadcast
hates him
21 in a row for fletcher he's not going
to be at the top as far as exit velocity
but you know what face it at the base it
for flats 21 games now for fletch five
for his last five in the series and more
importantly it puts a base runner aboard
for shohei oh johnny and there's a pop
that's going to drop in the same spot as
fletcher's for a hit fletcher's going to
go first to third the throw is late
shohei goes up the second and he gets
there without a throw ohtani read the
throw perfectly with the great speed he
saw that throw head to third base and he
already was taken off in on his way to
second base second and third on back to
back pitches two flares that have put
eduardo rodriguez in trouble right out
of the gate so here is walsh at the
plate and there's one grounded on the
right side stopped by arroyo from the
outfield grass he will throw out walsh
but scoring easily from third on the 4-3
ground out is david fletcher and it's
one-nothing angels gosselin won for four
yesterday oh look out point tony shohei
gets out of the way of that one i mean
that catch in an ankle that's a bad
scene
hot shot
he's got every skill imaginable he
really does and that's a little shallow
pop it's going to fall in for an rbi hit
gunsman on a 3-2 pitch brings in
chauhtani it's two-nothing angels
and rodriguez has got to be going are
you kidding me there has not been a ball
hit hard yet the hardest ball was the
out that jared walsh had
the other three hits we're all jam shots
this is another one fastball a little
cutter in
jams gazan but he's just able to muscle
it up get it out in the outfield angels
take 18 nothing lead and now here's a
guy that can hit it 500 feet ohtani with
runners at the corners all of a sudden
with two gone he got him beautiful
change up and ohtani swims over the top
of it for an enormous strikeout for
rodriguez jared walsh to lead it off in
the third two nothing red sox trailing
the angels what a nice play by bogarts
on this short hop man did he make that
look easy excellent backhand play right
here by bogey
just a one hop bullet to him nice and
smooth
got to his knees
look at this
one hop shot right there
nice easy to throw to first base to get
walsh it's back-to-back singles for the
third time already and we're only in the
third inning opportunity now for taylor
ward there's a cutter on the hands
that's popped up into shallow right
field and arroyo back to get it that one
didn't find green
that was close rodriguez is shaking his
head smiling coming off the mountain i
like the smile first and second with two
gone now for rafael devers who was
caught looking at strike three back in
the second inning only time that heaney
has been in anything close to trouble so
far today this is a chopper hit on the
right side fielded by fletcher he will
easily throw out divers and he pitches
out of a little bit of hot water
throughout jam here in the
top of the fourth inning and boston for
the second time this afternoon has a
runner in scoring position minute first
and third with one gone first pitch
swinging from dulbeck into left as
gosselin gets spun around and it's up
the wall
arroyo scores from third
and the red sox are on the board in the
fifth inning gosselin got fooled out
there and left christian must have
thought that gosselin was going to get
there and make that catch as it is
one run scores on a wall ball single for
bobby dalbeck that was wild biggest
threat to heeney all afternoon the red
sox have scored one two gun in the
inning now with runners aboard a little
blooper into left field will it fall it
will vasquez is gonna score it's the red
sox turn at some good luck a blue pit
for verdugo and we're tied at two
love he went fastball up and in
and verdugo got enough of it just to
kind of throw it out there left center
down that left field rather down that
line
basket ends up scoring anyway but
there's still one more run out there
that should be in 2-2 ball game as the
angels bat in the bottom of the fifth
inning and ohtani will lead it off and
he chops that one foul over on the first
base side right above the foot on that
one shohei
down in front that one there hit off the
back left knee he's got the front right
foot and the back left knee and he said
that yeah he would like that nice jog
around the bases now instead of have to
sprint around
there really is no one like him you
fouled him over your front foot you
found one off your back knee and what
are you doing you said you have to take
that little casual job and he rockets
that one out and it's already the most
home runs in a single season on july 7th
by a japanese board player in major
league baseball karen walsh the better
follows up with a drive to center field
[Applause]
so that'll bring the go-ahead run to the
plate in the form of christian arroyo
first and third with one gone arroyo
rolls this into center field and the red
sox are within a run bogart scores and
it's 4-3 in the sixth inning big clutch
hit by christian arroyo right in that
situation drives in bogarts from third
base they didn't quite have that same
shift
up the middle
and he gets that fastball and hits it
right back up the box here is walsh
who's had a two rbi day and there's a
swinging up high drive that's lifted
deep out into right field it's out of
here
that's a two homer day now for walsh and
the angels and on it's now 5-3
shitty is at third with nobody out
here's bogey he drives him down the
right field line and this thing is fair
extra basis for bogey when he though
slams into the wall martinez has scored
bogart's second double in a row he's got
27 and the sox are in business in the
eighth red sox are down to their final
out this afternoon [ __ ] hernandez the
batters six-game hitting streak on the
line hitless today
chased
over
missed then he struck him out as the
halos
beat the red sox five to four you can
put a halo over this one